wie ihr seht bin ich wieder in köln im
büro aber ich war bis vor kurzem in wien
und es gibt ein gericht das ist so
bekannt wie kein anderes wiener
schnitzel und ich war auf der suche nach
dem besten schnitzel in wien und habe
mir dabei hilfe geholt von lukas von
keinem geringeren als dem wiener dem
österreicher food blogger überhaupt und
er hat mir ein video gemacht hat mit
zwei empfehlung gegeben und welche das
den cds-markt mein lieber was genau
seine grüße aus istanbul schaut er dass
wenn ich da sein können in wien aber für
eine schöne schnitzel erfahrung hier auf
jeden fall dass meisten schaden besuchen
und den figl müller recker straße 6
plastisch merken man über uns nichts
mehr sehen uns
also auf nach wien erst mal ab ins
flugzeug und dann soweit wir angekommen
sind die wunderschöne stadt dienen
gerne
[Musik]
wohin gehen wir wer zuerst bist du
traurig
von
den leuten mal ein bisschen die stadt
zeigen denn wir nehmen
[Musik]
es war schon fast zu erwarten aber als
wir dann bei fiege müller angekommen
sind war natürlich eine schlange da und
man hat von außen schon gesehen dass das
nicht irgendwie imbiss oder sonst was
ist sondern das ist schon ein sehr
gehobenes stilvolles restaurant welches
sich zur aufgabe gemacht hat wiener
schnitzel zu perfektionieren und genau
das haben wir gesucht
hat die ganze zeit schon gesehen hier
ist alles top durchgetaktet der empfang
das branding innen drin es war einfach
so dass man sich gesagt hat wir wissen
ganz genau was sie tun und dann kam die
überraschung etwas mit dem ich wirklich
niemals gerechnet habe mir wurde
einstimmig von dem gesamten personal zum
schweineschnitzel geraten welches jahr
genau genommen kein wiener schnitzel ist
sondern wie eine art das kennt man ja
auch in deutschland und ich war so herr
kann ja eigentlich nichts sagen ich war
schon so moment mal dann habe ich beide
bestellt das kalbsschnitzel und das
wiener schnitzel und ich hatte nicht
damit gerechnet wie ihr seht wir haben
zwei verschiedene schnitte einmal der
klassiker das regelwerk klassiker
schnitzel das vielleicht beste schnitt
ist kein wiener schnitzel zumindest
bekommen wir das hier gesagt ich bin
sehr gespannt ob es stimmt was mir aber
direkt aufrufen ist schnitzel so viel
man ja so thema das wird quasi in öl
gebadet und dabei ist konstant in
bewegung und das schweineschnitzel hat
weniger von diesen charakteristischen
rasen hier sieht man das bei dem
kalbsschnitzel hat man oben steht ebenso
erhabene panade kein optisch sieht das
solide aus sieht das gut aus also
zweifelsohne ich erwarte natürlich jetzt
auch das aller krasseste es sieht sehr
gut aus aber es ist jetzt nichts was ich
noch nie gesehen genau das wollte ich
auch sagt also ein bisschen zitrone muss
auf jeden fall darüber gehört dazu bei
allen beiden und dann probieren wir
ich probiere die bisher ohne mayonnaise
ohne alles damit sie einfach den
vergleich habe
direkt das beste schweineschnitzel was
ich hier gegessen
damit ist wäre aber auch zu rechnen
gewesen jetzt ist das so wie die frage
was ist das beste schnitzel natürlich
eine präferenz fragen schmeckt man
lassen schwein ist ja es gefällt mir
auch besser als das culture hier und da
ist will ich was heiße weil ist es
natürlich viel schwieriger ein richtig
gutes schwein schnitzel programm als
einrichtet skype würde ich so sagen es
ist gar nicht mal so dass meine
erwartung und betroffen sind oder
irgendwas sondern ich bin gerade einfach
wo ich nur so am vergleich analysieren
weil ich will für mich selbst diese
frage beantworten was ist für mich
besser umgangssprachlich mann ist gerade
übels der kritische hase oder
[Musik]
deshalb beides sind absolut köstlich die
können wir uns jetzt rein und ich glaube
die endgültige entscheidung kann ich
sowieso nur mit ein bisschen distanz zu
haus treffen wir gehen jetzt erst mal im
nächsten jahr
[Musik]
ich habe mich in dem moment noch nicht
so wirklich getraut die realisation
auszusprechen aber in dem moment war für
mich das beste schnitzel in wien ein
schweineschnitzel also es hat irgendwie
ich verstehe dass sie es als ihren
klassiker als das besondere verkaufen
bei es ist wirklich unfassbar knusprig
ist es also wirklich undenkbar zart für
ein schweineschnitzel und die größe
einfach alles insgesamt ist wirklich
eine wahre erfahrung und auch etwas was
ich so noch nie erlebt habe also ich
habe noch nie so ein gutes schwein
schnitzel gegessen aber irgendwie dachte
ich mir dass es nicht so kommen würde
ich dachte mir nicht das beste schnitzel
ist ein schweineschnitzel und ich konnte
ja schon vergleiche ziehen mit
schnitzeln die ich bereits gegessen habe
beispielsweise hier bei uns in köln beim
grubers österreichisches restaurant wo
auch eine wahnsinnige qualität geliefert
wird deshalb war ich noch ein bisschen
skeptisch aber es hat schon das
potenzial eines der besten wenn ich das
beste schnitzel zu sein was ich bisher
gegessen habe wir haben ja noch einen
weiteren spot das meisten und schaden
und auch dort wenn wir uns auf den weg
gemacht für das beste hoffentlich beste
schnitzel dass wir in wien essen würden
und dazu erstmal ein mindestens genauso
viel
[Musik]
wenn man reinkommt kriegt man die jacke
ablehnung dann hat man diesen
wunderschönen kontrast zwischen modern
und alt und es ist einfach sein würde
man sagen ich habe mich sehr wohl
gefühlt und habe das aber natürlich dann
alles wieder scheuklappen angezogen
ausgeblendet und mir gedacht ich
probiere jetzt das vielleicht beste
schnitzel habs bestellt und alles
weitere seht ihr jetzt
vielen dank dankeschön
die präsentation des wirklichen 10 es
ist also wirklich wunderschön ich bin
auch diese täler mit goldrand erst so
richtig so wien für mich sie haben jetzt
ein paar tage hier ist es einfach eine
sehr edle historische stadt und kreis
nicht anders sagen ich finde jetzt
interessant weil uns wurde ja gesagt
weil viele müller dass die keinen kalk
schnitt zu nehmen weil das nicht so groß
wird cap ja also das ist offensichtlich
geht es ja auch sehr groß nehme ist mein
silberbesteck und schneider einmal rein
das ist es also dass vielleicht die
beste wiener schnitzel der welt ich muss
das auch erstmal tour wobei für den
perfekten vergleich auch mit ein
bisschen zitrone probieren ich bin
aufgeregt ist das jetzt besser als der
klassiker bei dem wahrscheinlich
berühmtesten schnitzelhaus in wien
butterzart muss hat eine echte
trendwende richtig schwere entscheidung
das ding ist das ist wunderschön finde
und das ist ja auch eine kunst das ist
so schöne blasen geworfen hat also was
sie genau das sieht sehr gut aus und ich
bin gespannt wie schmeckt
[Musik]
es ist krass gut jetzt heftig es ist
halt wirklich super knusprig und
radfahrer zu diesem diesen drahtseilakt
zwischen knusprig und zart meistert das
perfekt weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht
was besser sein soll tcl ex-freundin hat
sich das schnitzel mit butterschmalz
bestellt ich klassisch mit schweinen
schneit und dass sie extra knusprig aus
deshalb muss ich da auch noch mal ran so
schöne knusprige kannte also
butterschmalz
man schmeckt krassen unterschied dass
hier ist dunkler aber gar nicht mal
deutlich knuspriger und ich finde auch
vom geschmack her ist schweineschmalz
besser das wird richtig zu entscheiden
ich muss das eigentlich jetzt erst mal
auf messen und eric muss auch essen
man merkt schon dass sie die sache sehr
ernst nehmen weil man kann aus drei
verschiedenen öl beziehungsweise fetten
auswählen wenn die man das schnitzel
bestellt schweineschmalz butterschmalz
und pflanzenöle habe mich für die
traditionelle variante entschieden mit
schweineschmalz und ist es relativ
schwer weil wir haben ein unfassbar
gutes schwein schnitzel und ein
unfassbar gutes kalbsschnitzel das
schweineschnitzel knusprig sat 1
wirklich sehr sehr kräftigen geschmack
das kalbsschnitzel ebenfalls knusprig
mindestens genauso zeit ein boot regen
weichen geschmack am ende des tages muss
ich sagen das beste schnitzel in wien
für mich war in meinem aufenthalt bei
meister los haben es ist wirklich keine
leichte entscheidung gewesen weil es ja
etwas ganz verschiedenes war aber dieser
kontrast zwischen der knusprigen panade
die so wunderschön so friert ist dann
das zarte kalbsfleisch das habe ich so
noch nicht gegessen nicht mal bei grubes
ärgerlich werden richtig angst wir sind
nach wien geflogen und dachten kann das
eigentlich so gut sein wie da und ich
sage ehrlich es ist ein bisschen besser
aber ist es besser und damit es ist
definitiv das beste schnitzel was ich je
gegessen habe jobs auf jeden fall sehr
sehr schöne restaurants dankeschön an
beide dass wir dort drehen durften und
was soll ich sagen ich kann auf jeden
fall beide schnitze empfehlen das war
jetzt meine persönliche entscheidung die
wirklich nicht leicht gefallen ist ob
restaurants mit einer top erfahrung und
man hat auch wirklich das gefühl dass
man nicht einfach nur schnell zu essen
geht sondern dass man so eine wiener
schnitzel sind wiener schnitzel erlebnis
hat er steht ihr das ist schon echt
richtig richtig cool deshalb danke schön
ich könnte sie das schnitzel essen
[Musik]